here now with reaction is fox news legal
analyst greg jarrett and someone who was
in the courtroom today attorney to
former president trump elena haba thank
you so much for being here with us
tonight greg i want to start with you
because oh my goodness
hillary clinton personally signed off on
this personally hillary clinton herself
she personally approved the scheme
to peddle phony collusion information
to the media that dropped like a
bombshell by her own campaign manager
robbie mook and it seems so incredibly
foolish for the defense of all people to
have called mook to the witness stand as
fundamental in trying cases never call a
witness to the stand that only helps you
a little bit because the downside of
hurting you tremendously
is quite severe
and sure enough that's what happened i
mean mooc helped a little bit marginally
by saying well
we the campaign didn't put up susman
going to the fbi to the lie to them um
what the campaign intended is irrelevant
what's material is what sussman's intent
was
and his intent has already been
demonstrated by the evidence and the
testimony he put his lie to the fbi in
writing
so now he's only left
with some rather vacuous defenses he can
say well the lie was an itsy bitsy lie
that is it wasn't material as required
under law that's nonsense because the
fbi has said are you kidding
we wouldn't even have the meeting with
sussman had we known the truth he can
also claim the whoops defense gee i
didn't intend to lie i just misspoke
made a little bit of a mistake
that's not going to fly either and
finally
and he's going to claim i think that the
fbi figured out his lie so if they knew
it was a lie how can that be a genuine
lie
under the law
that wouldn't normally work in front of
a neutral and fair jury
but you know jason this is washington
d.c
yeah it is washington d.c and elena you
were actually in the courtroom
what was the atmosphere like how did the
jury react what happened in the
atmosphere right there in the courtroom
when it was revealed that hillary
clinton herself approved of this scheme
we've all been watching this for days
and i plan on being there every single
day to make sure i hear every bit of
testimony
this was amazing i never heard so many
pens click and start immediately writing
i
got reporters asking me for
clarification what did that mean what
did that mean are they in trouble and i
said uh that was very big that was very
big he just cut it right to the top and
thank you very much robbie mook for what
you did today uh made it very clear
there was a phone call
she paid fusion gps through her campaign
through her lawyers and that she was
actually told that there were papers
provided that had not been verified that
she had not and they said we had no dns
expertise we just figured the media
would take it and do their own vetting
now remember the media that they went to
was slate it was not the new york times
it was not the wall street journal which
maybe is a little bit more sophisticated
it was slate on top of that this was the
same time that she was deleting emails
and that she was having her own problems
with her servers so she and her team
have an october surprise and this has
been a real big theme by the durham team
and it's exactly what happened and then
october 31st ironically she retweets
jake sullivan's tweet that oh my god
cyber security crimes trump has a server
with alpha bank
complete lie
yeah
yeah
there are a couple of quotes i want to i
want to highlight for everybody here
that the first one i think is from uh
robbie mook who in his testimony and and
look at what he said here he said two or
three of the most damaging days of the
campaign
were caused by comey not trump and the
other one is and very interesting and
this goes back a few months actually to
hillary clinton if the election were on
october 27th i'd be your president
clinton said in may of 2017. now i
happen to be the chairman of the
oversight committee at the time that
this happened uh greg and the letter
from comey was actually addressed to me
and some other members of congress
and i thought about it i looked at it i
spent about a half hour with my general
counsel looking at it and decided that
there was no classified information that
the public had a right to know and i
released it
and uh
boy that sent them scrambling because
comey stepped in it again
and gave us this information and we gave
it to the public
yeah this is an attempt by robbie mook
to inject politics into a case about
evidence and the law
to try to unduly influence this
pro-hillary clinton jury which we
discovered during
jury selection
um
and it's also rather disingenuous
because mook's trying to suggest that we
would have never gone to the fbi with a
collusion story well in fact
declassified documents show that's
exactly what they did moreover
james comey you'll recall was hillary
clinton's bff
on
july 5th 2016.
he stood before television cameras and
spent about 10 or 15 minutes describing
how she violated the law with her email
server and then
in a complete about phase in the course
of 10 seconds he said but no reasonable
prosecutor would ever bring such a case
not his job he's a law enforcement
official he's not a prosecutor and in
the end the department of justice
spanked him big time for an abuse of
power usurping the authority of the
attorney general so this is robbie mook
trying to turn a case about evidence in
the law into pure politics for an
acquittal
yeah i actually thought comey was wrong
he for somebody he's not charging to go
forward and spend 10 minutes telling of
all the places that she broke the law i
i got to tell you honestly i just think
that was fundamentally wrong
nevertheless uh lena i want to go back
to you because it all comes down to
these 12 jurors as it relates to sussman
what else can you tell us about the
atmosphere how the jurors are reacting
to this how is the prosecutor received
is he is he the right person with the
right message is it too much about trump
what what's going on there in the
courtroom sure um the prosecutor um is
actually i think doing a
you know a fantastic job durham's team
has been very articulate they went up
they were brief and they had gotten what
they needed at that point and um you
know the media and the non-legal
entities that were in the room probably
didn't follow it as well but he was on
top of it
what happened with the sussman defense
was um
they've there's been times that we've
seen them become defensive with jim
baker we've seen um berkowitz become
very angry and remind baker that didn't
you say sussman was your friend didn't
you say sussman was your friend and and
try and in some ways i think intimidate
him and uh that was because
jim baker said very clearly that michael
sussman a hundred percent said to me via
text and in person that he was not there
for any client and that's really all
they need to prove there's only one
count here
the jury is a washington jury we are not
going to know what is going to happen
with them until
we see what their verdict is but i do
think it's becoming very evident what
what happened was a hundred percent
wrong they misled they obstructed
justice and the entire fbi was in on it
and in the campaign and the dnc
elena
and uh greg jarrett thank you so much
for joining us tonight on hannity we do
appreciate it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else